aux côtés de georges marchais l'autre
vedette c'est johnny hallyday qui donne
un grand concert demain à la fête de
l'huma à johnny hallyday en pleine forme
après son opération vous savez qu'on lui
a mis récemment une hanche artificielle
jean-claude d'arrigo et patrick voile
ont rencontré hier soir en normandie
et vous allez le voir il a retrouvé tout
son punch neufchâtel-en-bray 30
kilomètres de rouen mais tout premier
concert de johnny hallyday après ses
ennuis de santé et notamment ses
opérations successives à la rend
complètement libéré ne faut pas
dramatiser les choses que moi j'ai eu
dix ans et incident de parcours c'est
pas grave mais moins dramatique que le
cancer par certaines personnes et
d'autres maladies bien plus grave
je considère que je suis en bonne santé
j'ai la peau dure et
bon bah j'ai eu un petit accident ils
ont claqué dans que j'ai eu c'est un
petit peu comme si je m'étais cassé une
jambe au tour douleur voilà
un récital qui a une nouvelle fois
consacré les retrouvailles des fans
didier vincent et de la génération
d'aujourd'hui une espèce de répétition
générale surtout du concert de demain à
la fête de l'humanité avec à la clé bien
sûr la question peut-on pour un chanteur
connu participer à ce type de
manifestation sans être cataloguée
politiquement
je vois pas pourquoi je ne chanterai pas
dans une fête de la parti communiste
je n'ai rien contre le parti communiste
sont des gens qui nous ont accueillis
d'une façon formidable qui sont des gens
très courtois ils organisent une belle
fête tous les ans je vois encore plus
quoi bon toi des chanteurs comme moi on
n'y participerait pas on croit que ça va
être formidable je crois que ce qui est
formidable de ce concert c'est que ça
nous permet de jouer devant beaucoup de
monde
mais c'est toujours agréable quand on
fait ce qu'est de chantier le vendre
avant tout je chante pour des français
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ils sont des
français qui restent
tout autre chose maintenant